hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday
[Music]
Monday July 11th
2022
[Music]
.
how are you
you doing all right man it's [ __ ] 6
13 a.m Bill what are you doing up so
[ __ ] early
it's actually Sunday why am I up because
for whatever reason
I was laying in bed and I don't know
what time five-ish
in one of my spoke smoke alarms I don't
know it just went
my wife wakes up she's like oh my God I
think the battery's low at one of the
smoke alarms
and I'm thinking like was that the smoke
alarm or the house alarm
you know and then I gotta lay there
thinking to myself why did I stop going
to the dojo in [ __ ] 1999
why did I only go four times
you know
I could go down there like passenger 57
and just handle this [ __ ] but I stopped
going
um
and then I was just up so I figured hey
man
I'm up man [ __ ] it why not [ __ ] go
out God damn
[ __ ] garage
knock out the podcast well I can only do
the first half of it because it's so
early I don't have uh I don't have your
guys questions for the week
you know will you ask me advice because
you're too cheap to get a therapist
I know what you're up to gas prices go
up something has to be cut
and what do you cut first what's one of
the first things you cut your own Mental
Health
I know what I do
instead of talking to this therapist
who's been trained professionally
I'm gonna talk to a bald orange man
who has no psychology background
whatsoever he even uses the word
psychology this probably wasn't even the
right [ __ ] word
I [ __ ] hated those words before spell
check
psychology psychological psycho
syphilis I couldn't [ __ ] spell any of
those goddamn words
you just said the guy what I said it's p
p-s-y-c-h
Ike right that's what it was and then
you had to go the rest of the way and
that was it is there one L
is that two
am I going to pass this class do I need
this class is this what the [ __ ] I want
to do
look at that hot chick over there why
don't I just walk up oh that's right
that's right
because um the color
of Donald Trump's tie
I don't know what I'm talking about
sorry
um
anyway uh
what a [ __ ] crazy day yesterday
just a crazy day I absolutely [ __ ]
crushed it
as a father but then I I flipped out
about something and I [ __ ] ruined it
you know
these [ __ ] [ __ ] I went to Home
Depot
you know that [ __ ] with you you know
that's like the perfect whoever scored
that commercial
for Home Depot just that sample
it makes you feel like you know how to
fix [ __ ]
right
like get down here and you know go buy
that crescent wrench and go fix your
[ __ ] sink
so I went down there like the house
husband I uh to buy a vacuum cleaner
that's what I went I didn't go down
there to get a [ __ ] Midas saw
right to get some new drill bits
to get a carbon fiber [ __ ] Hammer I
didn't go down there for that [ __ ] I
went down there to buy a vacuum cleaner
for my garage
because I'm a married man that's where I
live that's my uh that's my my uh
I like the garage I also like being
married by the way
I do but you know I don't know that I
could be married without a garage
I think those two go hand in hand I
think the second you say I do
right she gets all your money and you
get a garage and then it works then it
just works and all you do is keep them
happy
and uh your happiness is that they're
not mad at you
no I'm kidding
um my wife actually made me laugh my
[ __ ] ass off before I even got out of
bed
yesterday
I said something stupid to her and she
just [ __ ] trashed me
and I I was laughing like solid laugh
for like [ __ ] two straight minutes to
the point I got her to start like she
stopped being mad at me
um
I don't know what the [ __ ] and she had a
you know I would say that she's mad at
me but I also then I I never really
quite say what I did
to make her that way you know
what is what is called as a one-side
story which is what you know hairy
legged white chicks really enjoy on
social media the old one-sided story I'm
gonna say what happened and then that's
gonna be it because that's what happened
cause I'm white and have a vagina
that'd be a good name for a [ __ ]
sports team the white vaginas
that probably comes off as
probably racist on some level like not
racist that comes off as uh
white supremacy
can you imagine if you had just like a
[ __ ] just a racist League
the supremacists
instead of the White Sox the whites oh
shut up Bill all right anyway plowing
ahead
um
it was a bad idea for a sketch even in
the 70s
um
so I just had to I had a great [ __ ]
day you know I uh
I just hung out with my kids all day
you know
um
I was just listening to my daughter talk
and looking at her and just you know
they make like these cognitive leaps
where like the conversation all of a
sudden out of nowhere is just like
and you always realize it like usually
after you walked away like wait a minute
wow
that was a
A Way Beyond conversation that I've had
with my kid since
ever you know God I'm stupid I can't
even [ __ ] I can't literally can't
even communicate my [ __ ] thoughts
um maybe if it feels like she's making
cognitive leaks because I'm so [ __ ]
stupid maybe that's what it is
um
yeah so I was just talking I was like
literally like just taking her in
you know you have a moment in your life
you're like I'm gonna be I'm gonna think
about this in the future
and you realize it like in the [ __ ]
moment those are always great if you can
do that so it's doing that
and I got this new thing with my son
because he uh
you know he has like these meltdowns you
know he's two years old he just [ __ ]
like
and it's not the terrible twos
like they say uh it's
been doing it since he was one
he just when he gets something in his
hand that he wants and he doesn't want
you to get it like first of all he puts
a death grip on it and he screams like a
[ __ ] wild man
so
um
the way I grew up is what you do as a
dad then all the dads in my neighborhood
my dad will all be like God
off is that [ __ ] yelling at a baby
start yelling at a toddler like I cut
you off in traffic you know that's
that's just how dads were back then
that's what you did
you had bass in your voice and you
[ __ ] used it you turned it up to 11
and you screamed at a [ __ ] one or
two-year-old and you made him pee a
little bit and then they gave up the
[ __ ] frisbee or whatever the hell
they had back in the 70s right
but uh you know
I see how I turned out and I'm like okay
maybe that's not a good approach
you know
so
I do this thing that I just I literally
just rub his head I'm like buddy buddy
you can't do this you can't throw stuff
at your sister
you know you can't
push your mom like he like he gets mad
and he like
he wanted to sit in my car right that
ass car Daddy's car and I I you know I
was like buddy I have to get ready to I
don't know what the [ __ ] we were doing
so I said I'll do it in a minute he's
like no no no no no and I close the door
and he was like yanking on the door and
I'm like buddy relax and then he just
ran at me screaming with both arms over
his head
and uh
I just ran into my leg like he just
threw himself into me and then he fell
down and he started crying
and uh
I just got this thing you know
I just sort of sue them
and it's really been working
my buddy buddy you can't you can't do
that just relax it's gonna be fine then
he goes like
these big little kid tears
um
yeah we're starting to you know turn the
corner with him where I noticed
yesterday it only happened a couple
times where it was like
you know I was told you I was a little
embarrassed when I was coming back
from France as far as like all right I'm
too much of a push over here with my kid
and I started to turn it around on the
flight where you know it's funny
little kids they know when you're not
[ __ ] around even if you're a pushover
they know when you're serious
and they might push back a little bit
but then they're kind of like all right
I think I'm uh
I think I'm pushing the Privileges here
so
um
I had a great day like hanging out with
him
like playing catch with them I didn't I
haven't even had to teach them how to
play catch you just can [ __ ] do it
it's amazing
and my daughter threw a spiral with the
football yesterday I freaked the [ __ ]
out
um
and I was getting along with my wife but
I just kept having these [ __ ] little
outbursts during the day and I'm like
why
is my temp UPS back like this
and I think I'm just stressing out about
you know
just all the work I got in front of me
and all of that [ __ ]
and also you know what it is is I
[ __ ]
I just kind of hit the wall with like uh
just substances and [ __ ]
and I'm like what am I doing
I'm [ __ ] drinking a coffee every day
now when the [ __ ] did I ever drink
coffee
I'm smoking cigars like it's going out
of style
and um you know I'm back to [ __ ]
smoking weed or eating a gummy like
every [ __ ] day and I was just like
you know what [ __ ] this
[ __ ] all of this [ __ ]
I'm not doing any of this [ __ ] I just
shut it off and I'm not gonna lie to you
the first two three days is always hard
and then now I'm on the fourth day and
I'm just like
I'm like whatevs man
see that's how I know I'm not like a
[ __ ]
you know I feel like addiction is a
spectrum you know what I mean well they
when I grew up they used to be like you
really were [ __ ] addict or you're not
you had the disease you don't I don't
believe that I I feel like there's all
different levels of it I you know I've
been to AAA meetings I got arrested for
drinking and driving and was required to
go to two of those and I'll never forget
those meetings I I always remember this
thinking like you know I I drink I don't
[ __ ] drink these people are out of
their [ __ ] money they out of their
[ __ ] minds I was joking with a buddy
of my yesterday like I just I went to
those meetings I just didn't relate to
them
bunch of [ __ ] yellow fingered donut
eaters
you just everything that they did
they're gonna smoke cigarettes they
smoked it all the way down to their
[ __ ] to the point their fingers were
brown and yellow I never saw somebody
brown and yellow [ __ ] fingers in my
life
and just scarfing down Donuts anything
to get a rush to get a 50 what was
[ __ ] hilarious as we're all up to you
know uh [ __ ] sober I didn't want to
be in the back like you're still killing
yourself you're [ __ ] smoking a pack
of cigarettes
during the meeting and you're filling
yourself up with [ __ ] sugar
yeah you won't die a cirrhosis of the
liver but you'll die a heart disease and
then all those [ __ ] uh friends of
building and be like it was a success he
gave himself he realized he was
powerless against his father
um
they should have a room right next to it
you know uh cigarettes and donuts
anonymous
[Music]
I actually don't think it's like that
anymore
um
I mean I literally went to those
meetings like [ __ ] over 30 years ago
how fast time's going by so anyway so I
think because I uh
you know
just getting these substances out I just
been a little [ __ ] short
shoes
and um
I got my truck washed
and uh you know I had some work done in
the garage
and you know they had cut a little bit
of the sealant out they got this [ __ ]
dust all over the place by the way I
love when somebody comes over to your
[ __ ] house to fix something and if
you have tools lying around they just
[ __ ] just start using them
you know what I mean like I had a ladder
in the garage and I see these Footprints
and these guys just [ __ ] use the
ladder
you know what I mean like like my like
all of my [ __ ] gets drafted into their
little [ __ ] War they have to fight
like fixing six bring your own [ __ ]
tools use your own [ __ ] tools you
[ __ ] they do it all the [ __ ] time
they're like they're [ __ ] I swear to
God then another thing that I love too
is they don't give a [ __ ] they just they
just leave the door open because they're
walking in and out they can't open and
close the door you get all kinds of
flies in the [ __ ] house they've read
they're [ __ ] animals they come in
like [ __ ] grizzly bears
um
or maybe I just feel emasculated that I
don't know how to fix it but I'm just
going to make it be about that they use
my ladder and left the door open
um
I didn't even finish the [ __ ] story
oh so anyway so so I gotta I get my
truck washed so I'm like well I want it
to stay looking shiny and
become aboard
it's my F-100 it shifts on the column
that's what I hang my manhood on it
shifts on the column
um so I'm like all right I need to
[ __ ] wash the tap
the car cover there so I can keep this
thing looking good right so I wash the
things the big stupid bulky [ __ ]
thing and I know good and God damn well
you can't you can wash a car cover you
can't dry it unless you have like some
Industrial Level giant [ __ ] you know
a dryer the size of a [ __ ]
refrigerator which obviously I don't
so um
I just hang it off the back porch I let
it dry old style
like step right up step right up come
and see the The Greatest Show on Earth
right like the old days
well the ladies would be out there
hanging their [ __ ] husband's wife
beaters
you know
wiping their tears and mascara off the
front of it
they would [ __ ] dry it in the alleys
I don't know if they would do that I
don't even they I just seen enough
movies where that's where they did it
you know
that's like one of those things like
um
you know like how Hollywood really
affects your perception
of uh
of people who aren't white you know what
I mean
I just ever since I've been like reading
these [ __ ] books and [ __ ] it's just
like I didn't know people acted like
that
I thought it was like it was in the
movies right
how they have like Native Americans you
know you know yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
making these stupid [ __ ] songs
that white people came up with oh they
acted like [ __ ] like black people
like all slaves were just scared
shitless of [ __ ] white people
um and then you read these books and
they weren't
they would give white people [ __ ]
you know after a while you know like
they would just
it's just like anything you could push
somebody so far before they like ah go
[ __ ] yourself
they're [ __ ] people
um I don't know if that made sense but
anyway
plowing ahead here
um I don't know what the hell this has
to do with the [ __ ] tarp but whatever
it's early in the morning I got woken up
by a smoke alarm
oh I don't know I was reading that that
that that uh Wilmington book
and it was like the cop would come down
and tell the black people all right you
gotta disperse you gotta disperse
they're like [ __ ] you we're not going
anywhere we're free and I'm like they
said that in the 1890s it's like oh yeah
why wouldn't they
people have been saying [ __ ] you I'm not
going anywhere since the goddamn caveman
days but once somebody makes a movie
who doesn't know what they're talking
about that becomes
your reference because I got to be
honest with you I lived in New York for
12 years I never heard one New Yorker
New Yorker go oh I'm walking here
never saw that
[Music]
I never heard any Italian go oh
then on The Sopranos and I'm not
[ __ ] on that show I'm just saying
I'm not saying it didn't [ __ ] happen
I'm just saying I know a lot of Italians
from New York and any I've never heard
them go oh
although I did hear forget about it
everybody said forget about it you know
until Donnie Brosco came out and then it
[ __ ] ruined it
ruined that because then I'll like the
[ __ ]
cinephiles if you would say it
you know yeah that's uh have you gone
over to uh you know so-and-so restaurant
is it good oh forget about it right
everybody said that right and then they
would go forget about it and you'd be
like all right it's over
it's over
that movie ended it
um
so my my truck cover dries
and I bring it out to the garage I put
the gay in garage by the way
uh because I don't know how to fix
anything right not saying that gay
people can't be handy
all right and I did mean that in a
sexual way
um
[Music]
so
I go out there with the [ __ ] time
and this happens to me every time I put
this [ __ ] stupid tarp on it's an all
black you know soft is a horse's muzzle
all right there's a [ __ ] reference
for you
and every time I go to put it on I can't
figure out which is the front and which
is the back because there's nothing for
the mirrors
it's just one of those ones that just
goes over it goes right over the truck
like [ __ ] when you do paper and
somebody else throws out Rock right just
right on top like that
like a spider on a bug there right so um
I
go to put it on and of course it's not
[ __ ] working I'm looking for the
[ __ ] hole that I cut for the antenna
and I don't know if moth's got at it
there's a bunch of [ __ ] little
microscopic little holes I can't find it
and dude
I [ __ ] had such a meltdown
so mad at myself it's like every time I
put this [ __ ] thing on I have to do
it like 15 [ __ ] times why don't I
just take a magic marker out and write
front on the front why don't I just
[ __ ] do that
so I got this piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
workout little bench
in my uh in my garage and I swear to God
if you even look at the thing one of the
legs collapses
and they got these things that you stick
into the little holes to make sure it
doesn't do it but it doesn't fit
or I mean I I don't know I don't know
what I'm doing wrong with the thing it's
just this classic
you know made in China ripoff of
something
that should have been made in Mexico
because that's where all of our shits
it's either in China or Mexico I feel
so
um
I threw that across the garage
because what ended up happening was in
my frustration of taking it off again I
[ __ ] yanked it up
and I hit the the ceiling which is Dusty
from the guy's [ __ ] cutting it and it
made the tarp dirty and I didn't realize
that the car cover and I put it on my
truck and I got my truck dirty I was
just like
like I was so [ __ ] upset with myself
that I was really like [ __ ] this I go
inside and I go I'm getting that giant
white piece of paper and I am just
[ __ ] writing front on the front of
this [ __ ] thing when I finally got it
together
um
and wrote it on a piece of paper and
then I taped it to the front and I'm
thinking like well what's going to
happen when I go to wash
this thing and I got this piece of bed
I'm like I'll [ __ ]
[ __ ] it I was upset so I go in
to our copier
little thing right to get the piece of
[ __ ] paper
and
of course there's like toys
on top of the copier and one of them had
like a little bag or whatever and I was
just thinking I would just lift it up
but I don't even know why I was why I
would even lift it up
I don't know why I even did that and the
bag tipped over in like 40 000 [ __ ]
things so plastic Easter egg looking
thing spelled out
and I just snapped I go what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] and I just lost my [ __ ]
ever so briefly but that was just enough
to [ __ ] the whole day up
right
then I go over
and by the way if if you're an aunt or
an uncle an aunt or an uncle how are you
supposed to say it
right
and you you buy toys
for your niece and nephews that has 5
000 [ __ ] pieces you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you're especially if you don't have kids
if you don't have [ __ ] kids I don't
look at that as an excuse that's your
passive aggressive thing you're upset
because you don't have [ __ ] kids you
want kids and you don't have kids so now
you're gonna try to make my [ __ ] life
miserable by by buying them a [ __ ]
thing that has like 50 000 [ __ ]
pieces to it
and the only time all those 50 000
pieces are going to be all together is
the first time I open the box and then
after that they're going to be all over
the [ __ ] house right
Oh Billy no substances he's on one today
baby
um
so I uh
I go over to the counter and I write
front in big fat [ __ ] letters with
the shoppie and I start coloring it in
and I get I color in the f I get halfway
through the r and I said oh no is this
going through the paper and onto my
counter and I look through and sure
enough it did and I was like what this
is just one of these [ __ ] days right
so now I'm [ __ ] scrubbing it and of
course it's not coming off
right
and I deliberately got the granite
countertops
because uh those other ones the the
marble ones it's just whatever gets in
them it just it just absorbs it into it
and you can't get it out it's like stuck
in there like that guy under the ice in
the omen right
subscribing it's not coming off
dishwashing thing I finally get it to
[ __ ] come off and I'm just like this
[ __ ] day right
I didn't even tell you what happened my
I bought a [ __ ] shop vac at Home
Depot this is what really set me off is
when I bought it I saw a little piece of
tape over the flap that opens the box
I'm like wait did somebody return this
thing and I was already standing in the
line I turned around there's 10 people
behind me I'm like I'm not going back
I'm sure it's fine I bring the [ __ ]
thing home it looks like somebody
vacuumed out like a [ __ ] barn find
piece of [ __ ] car with a mouse nest in
it the thing was filthy it's [ __ ]
filthy
so now I got to go back
get that Dana back to [ __ ] Home Depot
and I know what these [ __ ] are gonna
say to me they're going to say well how
do we know you didn't do that it's like
buddy I'm not trying to [ __ ] return
it I'm trying to exchange it
at some point I'm gonna drop the F-bomb
and I already know what I'm going to do
I'm gonna leave that [ __ ] thing with
him and be like this is my gift to you
you can put it back on the shelves dirty
like you did before like this is why you
go to Mom and Pop
you can't wait you go to a mom and pop
thing and they got like [ __ ] two
options or you go to Home Depot they got
every a million options and two
employees
and and and and you you go and buy
something that somebody already [ __ ]
used and returned
I don't even think it had the [ __ ]
filter in it
so oh Bill oh Billy's on edge right so I
[ __ ] come back out
uh this has a happy ending by the way I
[ __ ]
taped this giant white thing that says
front like there's no [ __ ] way I can
ever screw this up again
um to the front of it
okay oh my God this [ __ ] I was giving
myself
it's like why don't you write front on
it why do you go through this every time
it's like why don't you save any of your
[ __ ] passwords for your [ __ ]
accounts on the internet why do you set
yourself up for this
why are you such an add [ __ ] idiot
right
so
I was like all right do I really want to
bring this energy back into the house
again
no I do not so
I closed the [ __ ] garage and I sat
down and I played my drums which I've
been doing because I've had a little bit
more time now so I'm getting towards the
end of this edit of this movie that I
think is going to be [ __ ] great I'm
very excited about it
um I sat down and played [ __ ] drums
and uh
I'm gonna tell you this dude my [ __ ]
right foot was on fire I was so [ __ ]
mad that I I don't even and I didn't
even have my cell phone I didn't give a
[ __ ]
and I started playing like these bottom
phrases and I swear I think I was the
closest to playing good times bad times
I was [ __ ] burning through it and I
was also [ __ ] with that um
that licky does on uh I can't quit you
babe
where he it's a it's a 16th note triplet
followed by uh like three in a row it's
like
good dad boom
it said that I could never get after and
I started [ __ ] with that
and I just kind of came up with this uh
this bass drum exercise going in and out
of three in a row and 16th no triplets
um which is just like a technique thing
but if you do the two separately when
you try to do one after another
you know up to Tempo it always falls
apart and then you get upset and you'd
be like I'm never gonna
as opposed to just trying to
work on going in and out of both of them
at a Tempo you can handle that's what I
started doing and I was so [ __ ] mad
not to mention warmed up walking back
you know and forth from the [ __ ]
house the blood was flowing so the limbs
weren't cold
um
I [ __ ] crushed it so
uh
I was psyched about that I came inside I
apologized to my wife I said
sorry I screamed
[ __ ] and uh goddamn Home Depot Orange
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm sorry I yelled that in
the kitchen and she's just looking at me
like
like she should be looking at me
[Music]
and I'm like uh
I said all right I'm gonna do stand up
tonight I'm gonna give you give you a
break from me and she just starts
laughing so I ended up going out
and uh
I went down to the comedy store and I
went up and I just went out in front of
like this absolutely perfect crowd
there was so much [ __ ] fun and
I tried a few new things I talked about
my day with the goddamn shop vac
and uh
it I had one of those sets was just
every reason why I did stand up and they
would ask me if I wanted to go up in
this other room and I said yes before
that set and then after the set I was
just like I'm good I'm good it's not
going to get better than that I'm not
gonna [ __ ] chase it
and um
so it did it did have
a nice a nice ending there and then I
you know got my my wife something to eat
on the way home
and everything was good
so today I'm going to be hanging out
with my son
um because my wife's having a you know
mother-daughter day with my daughter so
uh I'll probably take my son up and down
the driveway in the truck
we'll play catch
uh maybe go to the park
something like that
um
it's gonna be [ __ ] awesome I'll do it
I didn't even bring up the [ __ ] Red
Sox Yankees series I watched every
goddamn inning of that so far
well mostly you know when I wasn't
[ __ ] walking into that I was
screaming about [ __ ] Home Depot
um
I don't know if you guys watch these
[ __ ] games can you ever type your
password and write the first time does
that ever happen
doesn't ever happen for me I don't feel
um
[ __ ] Red Sox man first of all the
Yankees are [ __ ] unbelievable I mean
Jesus Christ
they're they're on a tear here but the
great thing
is is all we have to do is get the wild
card so I'm kind of hoping that the
Yankees win like 130 games and have one
of the Great
you know regular seasons of all time
because all that does is work
to the Red Sox Advantage because then
it's just like they're supposed to win
it so the pressure is on them
and we can come in like the [ __ ] yeah
we kind of backed in ditto we're playing
with house money
so um
of course we go to play the Yankees and
it's just like our entire starting
rotation is out
and I'm like they're gonna [ __ ]
massacres
like we started we're starting four
rookies
we haven't done that in 60 years
four games in a row starting four Rick
rookies from the Worcester Red Sox I had
no idea Pawtucket shut down
I guess somebody you know bought the
Pawtucket Red Sox was trying to get a
new stadium which I don't know what the
[ __ ] was wrong with the other Stadium
it's a minor league park
granted I didn't buy it and see what the
plumbing looked like
um
they [ __ ] uh they moved to Worcester
and um
I got to go to a game out there so
anyways they bring up like
three rookies that can have another one
today
um
and the first game like
I don't know we get like we let up like
[ __ ] Grand Slam I think
it was like four to nothing and then it
was like
yeah it was four to nothing
and then Devers of course comes up hits
a [ __ ] home run he walked the first
time then hits a home run makes it four
to two then it became six to two
and then Devers comes up later and hits
a three-run home run
to make it six to five
and um I want to say that's how it
stayed it was sort of respectable six to
five seven to five
and then the next day we got [ __ ]
shelled still scored like five runs or
whatever
I do like that with scoring runs on them
like my fantasy is that [ __ ]
you know they kick our ass now and then
when we hopefully make the playoffs we
meet him in the playoffs sale is back
evaldi's back walk us back was it
pavetta Nick pavetta's back
and uh you know our bats get hot but uh
I gotta be honest with you like the
[ __ ] Yankees it's just like
I I mean I don't know what they're
spending their money on they somehow
have a 200 million dollar team and I
don't like I don't know anybody on that
I know judge Aaron judge I know I know
Rizzo's having a good year
and then everybody else I'm like who the
[ __ ] are these guys I mean dude they had
a guy on the mound he literally looked
like a dad from the bleachers
and I don't know what his name is
because the [ __ ] Yankees
they don't have their names on the back
of their jerseys
you know
since way back in the day back in the
day when they were like the [ __ ]
Bronx bombers their deal was we're not
putting our names on the back you know
who we are right some [ __ ] like top
shelf [ __ ] talk which made sense
you know back then I mean damn Ruth Gary
DiMaggio
Mickey Mantle and then all the other
guys that you know Yogi Berra Whitey
Ford Billy Martin all of those [ __ ]
guys
Dawn Lawson
right you didn't need to but now I'm
looking at the Yankees and it's just
like guys I don't know who the [ __ ]
these people are all right there's the
internet there's a thousand [ __ ]
channels this isn't the 1940s what I'm
[ __ ] walking around you know painting
a fence to get an apple
and I got a bunch of baseball cards and
I'm flipping them in an alley
you know he's gonna be
[ __ ] doing that [ __ ] it's like put
your name to the
forms so I don't know any of their names
but I will tell you my favorite [ __ ]
Yankee right now
is the guy he covers for for uh Aaron
judge
and they was saying he looks like Don
Matt I think Crawford
um is his name they say looks like Don
manningly he goes no I'm like no he
doesn't he looks like the gator man he
looks like [ __ ] Ron Guidry
who I loved when I was growing up except
when he was pitching against us
especially in 78 but I mean that guy was
just like [ __ ]
guy weighed like 160 pounds it was just
mowing down people
um
so uh he's got like this looks he looks
like a [ __ ] State Trooper
like he's on Reno 9-1-1 right whatever
the [ __ ] that whatever the hell that
name show is right he goes up he's got
the old school mustache no batting
gloves
my ass [ __ ] amazing because I saw one
of their other guys it wasn't Aaron
judge it was somebody else who hits a
bunch of home runs right okay it's a
bunch of home runs he I think it was a
DH whatever his [ __ ] name is right he
goes up and it's like the guy's a
monster and he's got like this [ __ ]
like entire like elbow
tricep forearm
like he's in the medieval manner he's
gonna have a sword fight
these [ __ ] guys now it's ridiculous
they come up there they're [ __ ]
they're dressed like like goddamn
gladiators
and they're hanging all over the plate
and God forbid somebody drills them in
the back of their [ __ ] ass right as
opposed to the front of your ass I was
gonna say the back and the ass I got a
little Tongue Tied there then they gotta
charge the mound like how dare you hit
me and every time they hit a home run
they stand there staring at it it's like
I don't understand that [ __ ] I don't get
that look he should be able to celebrate
what he just did
uh yeah and then the next guy gets
[ __ ] drilled in the ribs that's how
it worked that's how it [ __ ] worked
um
I love how you're not allowed to do that
anymore like you know but the other
person's allowed to to have like a
borderline Broadway show every time they
hit a home run I'm not just saying the
Yankees dude obviously the [ __ ] you
know I watch Deborah's just stand there
watching his home run like they watched
the Home Run and then they look at the
picture it's like you're just begging to
get beamed
foreign
I mean what do you do after that you
walk into a bar and grab some guy's
[ __ ] girlfriend and kiss her and then
stare at her then you get punched like
the [ __ ] was [ __ ] what's that all about
um yes that is the social equivalent to
watching a home run you just hit off a
guy and staring at the pitcher I believe
it is
okay that might be a little tone deaf
um
so anyway and then yesterday I'm having
like the worst day ever and then all of
a sudden it you know I [ __ ] play some
drums
right I'm crushing the 16th no triplets
uh the whole day turned around and then
I'm watching the [ __ ] Red Sox
I had to get ready to go out I jumped in
the shower
I missed you know as Thai school was
three to three and the Yankees were up
and I'm like all right I might miss the
top of the ninth whatever
shower shaved ahead and everything I
come down and I'm like what the [ __ ] it
was three or three now it's five to
three I'm like these [ __ ] guys man
they reminded me of the 1998 New York
Yankees where one of the things that I
loved about that team was I don't think
I ever saw a team score more goddamn
runs with two outs
they were just they were they were the
best the best [ __ ] team I think I've
ever I've seen in my lifetime
the 1998 New York Yankees they were
[ __ ] amazing so
um
I'm like God damn it you know like I'm
not one of those sports fans I I just
like
so if you're doing it you're doing it so
I'm just like these [ __ ] God
damn it they're [ __ ] great
so we ended up tying it up in the bottom
of the ninth and uh
anyway we ended up getting like two on
or whatever the [ __ ] happened
I don't know I can't even remember
[ __ ] kids and running in and out and
doing all of that [ __ ] all I know
is uh
we ended up [ __ ] winning on a
walk-off by uh old Dougie there
um well all of a sudden I can't remember
his [ __ ] name I think at this point
at my age I need the names on both the
home
and the away team Alex Verdugo
um and there was two outs we had a guy
in second and third they actually
bobbled
their third baseman whatever his [ __ ]
name is the guy who gets into it with
the guy in the White Sox whatever that
guy's name is right
um
it was potentially a double play ball
and uh he failed it he just had a weird
thing where his finger got caught in the
glove or something like that just
luck went our way and uh Runners
Advanced to second and third he threw
out the guy at first
um
I think it was Xander Bogarts and then
uh Verdugo came up and I'm thinking
there's two outs so anything hit these
guys are running so a single
a single to right could [ __ ] win it
and lo and behold single to right which
I swear to God Verdugo stood there and
watched that it's like well you get the
[ __ ] first base
Jesus Christ you'll lugging all that
weight down with that giant gold chain
um I'm gonna get one of those things I'm
gonna buy a giant gold chain just
[ __ ] walk around after every other
joke I'm gonna have to tuck it in
and there was uh yeah walk off single
and I [ __ ] screamed like we just won
a playoff game
um
so whatever so we have some other
Worcester uh Prospect pitching tonight
against the Yankees I mean what are the
odds we're going to beat that team again
I mean they're [ __ ] their goddamn
Buzz saw but I got to be honest with you
like I don't I don't know where this I
got to look at their payroll I'm kind of
fascinated now like like how much money
are they spending on these guys I never
heard of obviously you know Aaron judges
like [ __ ] Paul Bunyan everybody knows
that guy
but all the other ones I'm kind of like
this looks like a [ __ ] mom and pop
team like I can't I can't sit here and
say this is like a bunch of free agents
they still get that guy from the Marlins
whatever the hell his name is I don't
[ __ ] know
um
so this is one of these days where I
don't even need reach I'm just gonna run
my [ __ ] Yap
you know what I'm gonna do a little uh
the advertising reads here
and then I'm gonna uh
I don't know what I'm gonna do I'm just
gonna [ __ ] wrap this thing up and I'm
gonna talk about
Sports history how about that
Sports history for 200.
um oh look who it is everybody
it wouldn't be a Monday morning podcast
with without OH ZIP
now zip recruiter wouldn't need to have
their name on the back of the Jersey I
know who the [ __ ] they are you know
nothing is better than dealing with
someone who knows how to do their job oh
absolutely nothing's better than buying
a shop vac that's supposed to be brand
new and it actually is
anyway you know outstanding Talent is
crucial for a successful business maybe
Home Depot could [ __ ] use zip recruit
if whoever stocks their goddamn shelves
and if you're hiring you can find talent
for roles like these and more at zip
there we go uh when you try it for free
at ziprecruiter.com Zipper crew uses its
powerful technology to find and match
the right candidates
um up with your job you can easily
review these recommended candidates and
invite your top choices to apply why
don't they use zip recruiter when they
sell people guns
so you have the best [ __ ] you just
have normal people that want to shoot a
bunch of tin cans in their backyard why
don't you just why don't they do that
additionally zip yeah
um the devil Read has a complete Suite
of tools that makes it easy to filter
review and rate your candidates four to
five five employers who post on zipper
crew to get a quality candidate within
the first day
this is like one of those dating apps uh
no wonder zip
code is the number one rated hiring site
based on G2 satisfaction ratings
whatever that means as of January 1st
2022. I don't know what G2 satisfaction
ratings are but they crushed it
they crushed those ratings so travel to
this easy to remember web destination
ziprecruiter.com that's where you can
try zip recruiter for free again that
zip
ZipRecruiter
[Applause]
the smartest way to hire
[ __ ] I love the end of that I love the
ending of that copy that's like old
school advertising
you know
name of the company
little dramatic pause
but not not one that brings tension a
little pause
and then a little slogan
you know Dunkin Donuts
eat it you [ __ ] whatever that whatever
these this I don't I couldn't couldn't
think of one all right butcher box
[ __ ]
that's not a bad slogan that would make
me laugh and I'd be like you know what I
kind of got to go into that store and
see who owns it
um
that's like uh fat Sal's sandwiches out
here
first time I saw it fat cells and
underneath it says uh we'll make it
sandwiches over here and I was just like
I have to go in there and get a sandwich
I gotta see I gotta see who runs this
place all right butcher box everybody I
love butcher box everybody this summer
add some Power Players to your grilling
lineup with butcher bucks butcher box is
a subscription service that delivers
high quality meat ladies and seafood
right to your doorstep choose from a
carefully curated selection of a hundred
percent grass-fed beef free-range
organic chicken and wild caught in
Seafood you don't know what it's gonna
and more convenience every month butcher
box ships a curated selection of high
quality meat right to your home free
shipping for the continental United
States no antibiotics no or added
hormones
okay your daughter can eat a pork chop
without getting your period at seven
years of age
do you know that happens now there's so
many [ __ ] hormones that little girls
are getting their periods way earlier
than they used to you know and and where
where's the story on that where's the
outrage where's cancel culture run pork
chops nowhere to be found
nowhere to be found because they're too
busy police and comedy clubs oh Jesus
the irony people
the irony just exposed
right here
in real time on this podcast oh my God
I'm so deep
um convenience every month butcherbox
ships a curated selection of high
quality meat right to your door free
shipping for the continental United
States no antibiotics no added hormones
packed fresh and shipped Frozen
fresh and frozen alliteration all right
for your convenience so you can save
time on your next grocery store trip
customize your own box or go with one of
theirs either way you can get exactly
what you want it's high quality meat
delicious 100 grass-fed beef free range
organic chicken we already did this pork
raised crate free they let those pigs
run around before they shoot them in the
back of the head and wild caught Seafood
unbeatable value less than six dollars
per meal on average get Summer sizzling
started with this special butcher box
deal for our listeners free bacon free
bacon for the life of your membership
plus ten dollars off free bacon I mean
come on people come on
what are we doing here sign up today at
butcherbox.com
and use code bird to get one pack of
free bacon in every box for the life of
your membership plus ten dollars off
your first order and that's great even
if you can't eat all the bacon you can
go around town handing it out
yo and you when you die someday I'll
tell you about that guy you know
could be a bastard
not saying he wasn't a bastard but that
son of a [ __ ] always had bacon he
always make sure everybody
he always makes sure everybody ate uh
that's butcherbox.com and use code Burr
to claim this deal
I'm gonna start doing that walking
around town like I live in a little town
out here in L.A with my free bacon
call me old Billy bacon oh bacon Billy
coming around the corner who wants some
just holding that lifeless [ __ ] you know
I'd have to you have to [ __ ] cook it
first
can't just hand out raw bacon and
everybody's got to be wearing gloves
policy genius everybody
you know that reminds me of Pee-wee
Herman
peewee's big adventure when he ran out
of the pet store holding those [ __ ]
snakes he's like I just love that he was
such an animal lover that he actually
even helped the snakes he was a good
[ __ ] dude uh all right policy genius
um big life event coming up uh whether
you're graduating from school planning a
wedding welcoming a baby or switching
jobs Now's the Time to protect your
family's finances policy Geniuses is
your One-Stop shop to find the insurance
you need at the right place head to
policygenius.com to get started in
minutes you can compare personalized
quotes
from top companies to find your lowest
price I knew at some point the yawning
was going to happen
uh you can save 50 or more in life
insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius the licensed agents at
policy genius are on hand through the
entire process to help you understand
your options and make decisions with
confidence the policy genius team works
for you not the insurance companies all
right they work for you policy genius
doesn't add on extra fees policy genius
doesn't sell your info to third parties
policy genius has thousands of five star
reviews across Google and trustpilot
policy genius this is like like
[ __ ] your first
like if you were in college and you were
taking an advertising class
you know make sure you keep saying the
name we get it policy genius
since 2014 policy genius has helped over
30 million people shop for insurance and
placed over 150 billion in coverages uh
head to policygenius.com to get your
free life insurance quotes and see how
much you could save
all right
there we go policy genius everybody
and we are free and clear of the
advertising and now let's [ __ ] on
insurance companies you know what I hate
about those [ __ ] [ __ ] is all they
are about is collecting money
they are not about paying [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] unreal that's another group
of people that just what they get away
with
what they [ __ ] get away with is just
off the charts nobody gives them any
[ __ ]
none whatsoever where the [ __ ] is all my
my reads here all right I said I was
going to talk about
um
I was going to talk about sports so I
have a buddy of mine
I love the guy he's a big time Yankee
fan
and um I did a gig with him recently and
he was talking about he goes Yankees he
goes we're the best we're the best you
know because they got 27 Championship
nobody in any other sport
as like that many championships and you
know I break his balls and I'm just like
I mean
you guys were the best for the first
half of the last century
you know
you kind of slowed down wouldn't you say
I mean like
it's just like
I I have this thing with like sports
that this in every sport including
basketball with the Celtics
where so I'll [ __ ] on the Celtics here
all right where it's like
we went like 11 championships in 13
years we win nine in a row
all right
but you look at the league back then
that's when like 5 11 white guys
were all over the place
you know Will Chamberlain wasn't allowed
to dunk
you know what I mean Wilt scores a
hundred points in a game no one's ever
gonna [ __ ] do they like there's
always like these ridiculous [ __ ]
records
and I I just always feel like it's like
I get it you won the championship back
then but it's just like there's so many
different [ __ ] variables
um
you know to sit there and look at those
championships back then and I'm not
saying that winning a championship
wasn't winning a championship I would
never say that but like the sheer amount
like take like the Montreal Canadiens
that like you know they're counting
Stanley Cups back when the Stanley Cup
was like the size of a mug of beer and
you won it when you were playing [ __ ]
pond hockey
um
I'm just saying you know what I mean
like if you look at baseball
like how much the game has changed first
of all to win a World Series first of
all to win the pennant back then
all right it's like all you had to do
was have the best record in in the
American League or the national league
and that was winning the pennant whoever
had the best record that was it and you
went directly to the World Series so if
you had the best record in the regular
season all you then had to do was win
four games nowadays
there's 30 [ __ ] teams
there's all this nutrition and all of
these [ __ ] stats
that all of these [ __ ] nerds sticking
to computers to try to [ __ ] you out of
getting a hit
and then you make the playoffs as a wild
card team you now have to win was it 16
games
and play a possible 28 [ __ ] playoff
games
to do it
it's just not the same thing of course
nobody's ever going to go on a run like
that
same thing with basketball nobody's ever
going to win nine in a row although the
[ __ ] 90s Bulls
probably could have won five or six
which and to me that would have been
better than winning nine in the 60s to
win like you know seven if you won like
six to seven in the 90s to me that's
more impressive than winning nine in a
row in the Inception of a league
you know so my thing is like I kind of
like categorize [ __ ]
where it's like
you know you look at like like I always
love using this example like the last
person to hit 400 for this season was
Ted Williams
okay and he did that in the 1940s
I want to say 1946 I can't remember when
nobody has ever done it again
okay it's coming up on 80 years
okay more than three quarters of a
century nobody has ever done it
again however if you go the other way
and look at it somebody was hitting 400
like every other year and if you go far
enough back
you'd have a couple of guys would do it
in a year and if you go all the way back
to the 1800s they had like years where
three guys would hit 400.
all right so all of those [ __ ]
records from way back then all of these
home runs
like RBIs Hank Greenberg had a 190
[ __ ] home runs nobody's ever going to
break that record like guys in the 90s
in the 2000s literally had to do [ __ ]
steroids and go up there like a goddamn
X-Man to break records
done by by that that were were
um set by people who had off-season jobs
he plays right field for the St Louis
Browns and during the off season he
works construction
he hit 400 through a no-hitter and had a
190 RBS like back then like you would
[ __ ] literally like if there was a
double header it was like yeah Bill
you're pitching
it's like
the first game right now the whole
[ __ ] all 18 innings
I can't do that what's the idea I see a
pitch and see
so I mean I can only take that [ __ ]
like
you got it you got you gotta knock it
down a little bit like the way I look at
it this like
there's there's
the Inception of the league slash only
white people were allowed to play
championships
I mean don't you think it's kind of
weird that the last time somebody hit
400 it was still an all-white League
all right and then all of a sudden when
the Josh Gibson said Pedro Martinez Cece
sabathias and all this great talent from
other races is allowed to play nobody
ever does it again despite the fact that
you had guys like Mickey Mantle Willie
Mays Pete Rose
Tony Gwynn Wade Boggs all of these
Master [ __ ] hitters George Brett
nobody ever did it again
I don't know I I just feel I don't know
this just something about that so for me
I kind of look at it in my lifetime
so this is the argument I present to
this
my buddy who's a Yankee fan I just look
at it like this like
in my lifetime
if if I look at if you're gonna say with
with the best we have the most
championships there's sort of like you
know
it's like in tennis the pre-open era the
Post open era I have like the pre it was
white guys only and then the post now
everybody can play and now we really can
see what you're gonna do
okay and I'm not saying I'm not saying
that like
obviously the Yankees would still have
the most like World Series and all of
that and all of that type of [ __ ] and
I'm not saying that all of those great
Yankees couldn't play in any era but I
am saying though they went up against a
lot of white pitchers who wouldn't even
be in the [ __ ] League
because the Pedros of that era weren't
allowed to play
but I guess there was less teens it
wasn't all [ __ ] white
's death other than that it's pretty
[ __ ] slim pickets
[Music]
sorry I had to get that out
so as far as the way I look at it
in my lifetime and I hate to [ __ ] say
this the most successful franchise in
all four Sports in my lifetime is the
Los Angeles Lakers they've won 11 titles
all right and the uh
Montreal Canadians have won I think 10
titles
in my lifetime and then the Boston
Celtics have won eight
and the Yankees have won seven
so
there's an argument to be made like
they've been sick the thing about the
Yankees that I think makes them the best
of all time is they've only gone two
decades where they didn't win a
championship over the course of a
hundred years that's [ __ ] unreal that
really is unreal so I'm not saying that
they're not the greatest I don't know
I'm just saying like you know
it's kind of like the Celtics it's like
we have 17 titles so do the Lakers but
we won like like nine of those 11 of
those
um
during the 23 skadoo years
and then it's also and I I just feel but
then I also feel like at the NBA is like
rigged in a way where now it's like pile
on [ __ ] teams
so then it comes down to weather and
level of [ __ ] in your city
I feel
like you know I mean who's can who is
it's like you know
is Cleveland ever gonna have a pile on
[ __ ] team
you know and there's a bunch of dumb
people be like they had LeBron LeBron
was their guy
that was their [ __ ] guy so I don't
give a [ __ ] that he came back from Miami
that was their guy
it's like nobody is like the Indiana
Pacers are never gonna have like a
[ __ ] you know
like LeBron's never gonna go to Indiana
and then try to get a bunch of people to
come out
to [ __ ] you know uh
it's South Bend Indiana whatever the
[ __ ] they play right Indianapolis it's
just not going to happen so I find it to
be it's just sort of a uh
I know it's a weird thing whatever or
maybe it was just my Red Sox were
getting their [ __ ] asses kicked and
my buddy who's a Yankee fan was talking
[ __ ] and I just needed to come up with
an angle
um I just out of curiosity
okay because then you look at like like
what do you guys think about that
because if you look at like football
what I don't understand I I've said this
a silly times so I'll blow through this
is how they don't count NFL titles
um
you know they just count everything
after the merger with the AFL but
there's been plenty of
leagues
that have merged like the the [ __ ]
NHL has merged like two or three times
with other leaks
but yeah the expansion six I guess
that's not that that was an expansion
and then they had what was it the IHL
where they brought in like the uh the
Indianapolis Racers that became the
[ __ ] Edmonton Oilers
and they still count all those Stanley
Cups
you know all the way back in the day I
you know but for some reason like the
Green Bay Packer one one like like 11
NFL titles and they just that all just
got thrown out
um I think if you count NFL titles
then the most successful franchises of
all time would be I think definitely the
Green Bay Packers and then I think it's
the Giants
because the Giants very quietly
one in both errors they just had a
brutal from like once they lost Sam Huff
and Frank Gifford and all that oh they
were also kind of the Buffalo Bills of
the 1950s where they went to the title
game like I don't know like three or
four times in four or five years and
lost every time
but then they just sucked in the 60s and
70s and then [ __ ] a man named
Lawrence Taylor showed up
who to this day I don't think anybody
ever looked better in a [ __ ] football
uniform than that guy he just looked
like
like if you drew a football player
totally changed the position
did I ever see him live no I don't I
never did [ __ ]
I look back now and I think why didn't I
just get in my [ __ ] car
and just drive down you know why didn't
I drive out to the odd in Buffalo to see
a Sabers game or go down and go to a
Wailers game or drive down to [ __ ]
the Meadowlands and go see the Giants
with [ __ ] Lawrence Taylor and Harry
Carson why didn't I [ __ ] do that
you know why because there was no GPS
back then all right
and it just it was very intimidating
back then to drive that [ __ ] far like
I don't know where the [ __ ] I'm like you
had to go to the gas station and get the
really big map
you know and comedians just do bits
about that how you could never [ __ ]
fold it up again and you were just
completely [ __ ] and you had to squint
and point to the road
it was intimidating that's why there I
should have gone to the Spectrum I could
have seen Dr J down there at least scalp
the ticket
you know all those years when the
Celtics were great in the 80s I only
went to one game and that was uh I
scalped tickets to go see the uh then
play the Detroit Pistons the bad boys
and of course [ __ ] Isaiah Thomas
wasn't playing
but I saw the rest of those those
[ __ ] [ __ ]
um all right anyways that's the uh
that's the podcast here
I mean like let me know like what you I
mean I guess for sports history you
gotta you know you gotta count that [ __ ]
I actually thought this is one of the
thoughts I had after my smoke alarm woke
me up
um was
you know I was just thinking about
NFL titles and that type of [ __ ] and you
look at the uh the original Buffalo
Bills as far as going to the Super Bowl
not winning was the Minnesota Vikings
and it's just funny to me
that no one ever examines that
and thinks like why are they so snake
bitten like that year they were 15-1 and
they couldn't [ __ ] lose
and they just had like Randy Moss and
[ __ ] was it was it Randall Cunningham
and they just were [ __ ] electrifying
to watch and they lost to the goddamn
dirty birds the Atlanta Falcons
and they just like [ __ ] snake bit why
is it I have a theory as to why they're
cursed
you know like the Montreal Canadiens are
cursed because they booed Patrick Wah
you know they boot them out of the out
of their city and he went on to win two
cups with the Colorado Avalanche
formerly the Quebec nordics as we all
know right and they invited him back
years later because they kind of know
those Frenchies up there they kind of
know that they [ __ ] up
you know it's like uh rhyming the
Ancient Mariner but with with Patrick
Wah
um
I literally can't even remember the
[ __ ] point I was trying to make oh
the Minnesota Vikings
so a lot of people don't know this but
the Minnesota Vikings were part of the
original AFL they were an original AFL
team
they were down with the AFL
you know when the AFL came out the NFL
laughed at the AFL saying it's an
inferior league and all that [ __ ] and
they did two things to [ __ ] with the AFL
um the richest owner was Lamar Lundy
and he owned a team called the Dallas
Texans they had red and white uniforms
all red with the white
you know outlining the the Texas on the
side of their helmet so what they did to
[ __ ] with them was they were like all
right this is the rich as they said
publicly we're not worried about this
league they did two things to [ __ ] with
them before they even started was
they put that's what Dallas Cowboys came
about
because they're like all right we'll put
an NFL franchise in the same city that
the richest owner has one so we'll [ __ ]
with half of his gate
to hopefully make him go under and he
has the most money and then everybody
else will get disgruntled and leave and
then the other thing they did was they
took one franchise they went to the
Minnesota Vikings for whatever reason
Minnesota
they went to them and they said hey do
you want to just join the NFL
in Minnesota turn there
and sold out and joined the NFL
those turn coat [ __ ] and they
have been paying for it ever since
I and I actually believe
that Al Davis probably put a [ __ ] hex
on him
and they never made things right with Al
and unfortunately Al is no longer with
us because Al Davis when the AFL was
voting on whether or not to merge with
the NFL because they were seriously
hardcore [ __ ] with the NFL
they took a vote and I don't know how
many teams there were say there was 10
teams in a league at that point
um they agreed to join the NFL on a nine
to one vote there was only one guy that
said
went [ __ ] Tony Montana He said [ __ ]
the end
there was only one owner that said [ __ ]
them we're not joining we're putting you
out of business
and that was Al Davis so if he had that
type of [ __ ] blood in him which you
know he did
any [ __ ] you know older guy that
still has a [ __ ] diamond bracelet you
never [ __ ] wear sunglasses you don't
have a [ __ ] with an old guy that has a
diamond bracelet and [ __ ] sunglasses
that guy that guy will carry a grudge
until he gets you back and I'm telling
you I I think Al Davis put a hex
on the [ __ ] Minnesota Vikings I think
it's the curse of Val Davis
because I can only imagine what he said
those [ __ ]
he probably I I like if somewhere out
there
the original owners of the of of the
Minnesota Vikings has the voicemail
that Al Davis left them
you know you [ __ ] ballist pieces of
[ __ ] you said you were all about
starting this league and taking the
[ __ ] NFL down and they batted their
[ __ ] eyes at you and what did you do
you folded your phone hold it like a
[ __ ] lawn chair
I don't know why I don't know what he
said but you know if I I bet he I bet he
was like [ __ ] those [ __ ]
I bet he enjoyed every time every time
they lost the Super Bowl
wait a minute
the [ __ ] Raiders beat him in Super
Bowl 11. holy [ __ ]
and Sammy white went over the middle and
he almost took his [ __ ] head off
oh God he must have enjoyed that there's
got to be somebody must have written
something about that all right I'm out
of time here
um that's it I will read your questions
on Thursday
um because there's a bunch of Prague
Rock [ __ ] bands that people who are
going to be suggesting to me
um that is it I'm just [ __ ] with you
guys like Yankees fans and everything
you know
um
obviously know you guys you know
are the greatest franchise of all time
but like I'm just saying you know
because I threw the Celtics in there too
you got to admit you know
if you want you know a bunch of dozen
championships when it was just a bunch
of white guys
don't you think it really would have
been more like eight
seven
six all right that's it all right go
[ __ ] yourselves I'll check in on you on
Thursday